- Will I still love you after this?
- [Kevin] I think so. I could probably
wear this out, I think.
- Oh, my God, Is it like
the same outfit you have on?
- [Kevin] (laughs) No, no.
(upbeat music)
- So just a polo on
top, blue cargo shorts,
everyone had the multi-pocketed shorts.
- I still had this like
huge passion for Disney.
I used to wear a bra
and then wear a sports
bra over because my boobs
just grew so fast.
- I actually used to wear
all of my dad's clothes
from when he was in high school.
- I always wore lots of color.
I loved Hawaiian shirts.
- A mini skirt.
The layered like spaghetti strapped tops
with like a shawl over
the top or something.
And some sandals.
- He only likes blue, so
I think he just wears like
blue jeans, blue shirts.
- He probably had a little
more sophisticated style
than I did, for sure.
- I'm assuming it was a lot of plaid.
- [Mallory] Babe, will you still love me
if I look like a goober?
- Depends what kind of goober
I guess. (laughing)
(Mallory laughing)
- I feel like we're
role playing. (laughing)
(laughing)
- [Mikey] Oh, my God. (laughing)
Oh! What does that say?
- It says...
- Dawn of the Dead, you dork!
(laughing)
- That's the size you wore?
- You look really cute.
- These aren't skin tight.
- I know.
- What's that about?
- That's why I wanted to--
They still look good.
- [Bryan ] Honey, thanks.
- Yeah, these are like
mom jeans. (laughing)
- [Mallory] Mom jeans!
- It's cute.
- I would like tuck it.
- Did you tuck it in?
- Yeah, I'd tuck it in my jean hole.
- Did you have the cloth in the back?
- What?
- Did they come up with that?
(Kevin laughing)
- Who do you think I am?
- [Mikey] Were you skinnier?
- What do you mean?
- Was it bigger here
than these? (laughing)
- Yeah, I told you I had
like really big boobs.
- Oh, they receded?
All right. I'm coming out.
- All right. I'm ready.
(laughing)
You're preppy?
(Kevin laughing)
(laughing)
- Of course that would be
something you would wear.
- This is a little too
tight for me, I'd say.
- Yeah, it shows your moobs.
(laughing)
- No wonder you had had sex with women.
- I think you're gonna go get a mojito.
- Yeah.
- Wait, what does this say?
- Religions of Buffalo.
(laughing)
Shit happens and it happens to smell good.
- [Kevin] I wore this on Monday,
I probably would've worn it on Friday too.
- Ew, (mumbles)
(Kevin laughing)
Did you clean it?
- My mom cleaned it.
- You had your mom clean it?
(laughing)
Like you do now.
- In high school.
- Like you do now.
- You did your laundry
in high school?
I did my laundry in high school.
- It's probably be like
my best friend's mother.
- I feel like we look like
we would've been friends.
- Yeah, I probably wouldn't
even have noticed him.
- I thought you would've
been cooler for some reason.
I don't know why.
(laughing)
- But I saw her at the high school reunion
and I had known who she was, so...
- It makes me wanna watch
Dawn of the Dead now.
- I have it on DVD, we can watch it.
- We're gonna watch it? Movie night.
- Heyyy.
- I feel like this was
seeing each other naked
for the first time.
- Like a (mumbles) and you know.
(laughing)
A little bit disappointed but you know.